we have tonight speaking for us a
novelist we also have a journalist a
historian a biographer we have a
playwright it's all one person Richard
Rhodes is really is is a fascinating
person to have relay asturias looking
for stories and he's tells stories in
many different ways so it's a very it's
it's not at just the facts mam kind of
thing it is it is I think finding out
about the people and telling their
stories for them and finding the larger
story that forms from that tonight we're
gonna hear a lot of stories in one story
so the round of applause for Richard
Rhodes please thank you you know one of
the things I wanted to talk about just
briefly is where books come from this
particular book really came in this side
door I was casting around for a subject
having finally finished the nuclear age
and thought well wouldn't it be
interesting to just pull out one year in
the life of this country and somehow put
it together so that it made oh ears
worth of sense and being a modest person
I thought well I'll use the year I was
born actually I was thinking more of in
Moby Dick at the beginning when Ishmael
I saw the big headlines about everything
that's going on in the world that the
last little eight-point headline at the
end is one the Ishmael goes to see so
although I was aware that if I chose
1937 my birthday on the 4th of July
would be right in the middle that would
be fun mostly it was just a let's look
at this particular year so I bought a
year's worth of microfilm of the Kansas
City Star which I grew up in Kansas City
and started cranking the crank on my hum
microfilm reader and I kept noticing the
Spanish Civil War the star in those days
was a really high quality paper remember
that's where in as Hemingway learned the
beginnings of his particular kind of
prose style but here were dispatches
from Spain and I quickly got quite
involved and as I looked more into the
subject I'm always looking for the
technological and scientific and medical
aspects of a story partly because those
subjects interest me
partly because many of my books have
been supported by the Alfred P sloan
Foundation which is a foundation that's
dedicated to communicating issues of
science and technology to the general
public and gives good grants which makes
it possible which makes it possible to
actually make a living as a writer
something that's not so easy to do these
days the more I looked at the medical
part of the story the more intrigued I
was because it simply doesn't appear in
the 500 or so straight histories and
biographies of the Spanish war and yet
looking in the specialty literature in
the British and American medical
journals of the day I was surprised and
fascinated to discover just how much
had happened during this war that was
new in medicine I mean it's a truism of
wars that new technologies are often
developed under the pressure of need and
we all know and I will get to that in a
moment that there were several new
technologies of mass killing that were
experimented with and tested out during
the Spanish Civil War but I hadn't
realized the medical side and I'd let me
let me go on now and just simply fill in
a little bit of background let's see
which way we go yes here's a map of
Spain to give you some idea of the
nature of this war this is the whole war
so it's a little bit confusing and this
is kind of the end of the war when the
Republic was crowded into this central
part of Spain and Franco and his forces
had basically surrounded them but it was
pretty much the opposite at the
beginning of the war Spanish generals
someone says their highest ambition was
to stage a coup d'etat and save their
people and that was certainly true in
the summer of 1936 Franco and many other
Spanish generals had basically been
slowly pushed aside by the young
Republic that had taken power in Spain
in 1931 and had begun to try to deal
with all of the suffering and repression
that had been a lot of the Spanish
people for hundreds of years
dominated by wealthy landowners and a
church that had really betrayed them had
decided to cast its lot with the rich
and the powerful
there were basically no public schools
60% of the population was illiterate
Spain was still very much a kind of
third-world country
agricultural it was basically
agricultural except for the the
Catalonian region around Barcelona where
the Catalonians had moved more toward
the mining and manufacturing Spain is a
country of many kinds of minerals and
mines one of the reasons other European
countries have always been interested in
it but Franco in the summer of 1936 and
some of the other generals decided that
it was time to take power they construed
the the Republican government of Spain
which was a coalition government of many
different kinds of political parties
ranging from communists on the Left to
anarchists and wherever anarchists are
when I guess on the right
truly anarchists who really did believe
that you didn't need a government at all
so just in the in late July of 36 Franco
started putting together a force which
was interestingly largely North African
Berber mercenaries Spain had fought
several wars with the North African
people in the preceding years
that's how Franco had won his
generalship and his name as the youngest
general in the Spanish army in the 1920s
the wars had been brutal the north
african Berbers were basically tribal
peoples Franco's and the other generals
with the Spanish armies saw no reason
not to use poison gas which they did in
the 1920s long after the treaties had
been written
where everyone agreed not to use poison
gas now he was basically hiring these
Berbers in North Africa to fight as
mercenaries for he
against the duly constituted an elected
government of Spain but he had a problem
which was how to get them across the
Mediterranean they were in across from
from Gibraltar in the area around
Morocco and all the way over to that
part of North Africa across from
Gibraltar and the Spanish Navy which
stayed loyal to the Republic had
basically blockaded and destroyed the
little bit of shipping he had so he
turned to to Mussolini in Italy asking
for air support miscellany wasn't quite
sure who was running the show there were
other generals in Spain who were
fighting as well as Franco and wasn't
prepared to loan franco planes all by
himself so the next step was to send
some of his representatives Franco's to
to Germany and these men supported by
some German businessmen went to see
Hitler who was at that time listening to
vogner and the what is the town where
the vogner festival is held by root
right
Hitler had just come from from listening
to one of Magnus operas in was filled
with the music and when he heard these
men and asking for for air support he he
told them first that he said how much
money do you have and they told him and
he said well you can't win a war without
a little bit of money they hadn't tapped
into all the gold in Spain yet so after
but he warmed to the subject as if
vogner started flowing through his veins
and after three hours of talking to
these poor men who were waiting for
their dinner it was about 1:00 in the
morning at that point he gallantly said
we'll give you planes Germany had at
that point build a secret Air Force
which was officially Lufthansa but in
fact was a way of getting around the the
treaty that had been
at the end of the first world war that
said that Germany would be denied an Air
Force so Lufthansa originally was the
Luftwaffe and all they had to do
basically was convert their planes these
wonderful try motors that they had and
here we're seeing the the mercenaries
getting ready to be flown across to the
southern part of Spain across near
Gibraltar in what was and this is
typical of this little war the first
large-scale airlift in the history of
war Time magazine in 1937 called the
Spanish Civil War a little world war and
it did so because it was not simply a
civil war within the territory of Spain
other countries got involved for various
reasons Germany in part to support the
fascist movement in that part of Europe
but also and significantly as a kind of
testbed for the new technologies Germany
was developing in anticipation of the
world war that it was soon going to
precipitate such as aircraft new fighter
planes nuke new ways to bomb tanks which
weren't very good at first the Soviet
Union came in on the side of the
Republic in a similar way not on the
ground and the Germans didn't supply any
ground forces either but with the tanks
and aircraft that in this case the
Republic needed to defend itself and
there was kind of an arms race going on
all during the war between the German
aircraft and German tanks and a
particular German cannon which had been
designed as an anti-aircraft cannon but
turned out when set up horizontally to
be an incredible tank killer 75
millimeter very high velocity shell so
all this was going on and as Hitler said
conference and that winner of 1936 he
said we'll keep fighting this war to
keep the democracies busy over there so
we can keep our business going over here
so he saw several good reasons to be
involved in the war and basically came
in on Franco's side and on the rebel
side the nationalist side is it was
called the people this is an
extraordinary and famous photograph this
is a group of Republicans executing a
statue of Christ which which when it
appeared in the conservative London
newspaper shocked everybody terribly
because it seemed so blasphemous but the
church as I said had aligned itself with
the forces of repression in Spain for
the all the way through the 20th century
and there was a great deal of hatred of
the church and of its of its behavior in
Spain and all during the war was on
Franklin's side publicly announced as
such the bishops letter came from the
Vatican and was published all over the
world saying the forces of atheism and
communism are being fought in Spain by
the gallant people of Franco and his
North African mercenaries who weren't
even Christians although they were
wearing breastplates with the cross on
them so these statues have been put up
all over Spain a great expense at a time
when people didn't have enough to eat so
the the execution they also executed in
the early weeks of the war about 6,000
priests and exhumed the bodies of dead
nuns and priests from the various
catacombs around the country to show the
people that they were mortal that they
rotted just like any other corpse if you
will as soon as the spanish republican
government really took control of the
all of these basically
militia level military forces that were
coming together to to try to repel
Franco's forces in the early weeks of
the war a lot of this atrocity
level killing was suppressed however
Franco's side continued throughout the
war it was typical of Franco's approach
to the battle that he he wanted to take
each town and control it before he moved
on to the next one because he understood
that the people were opposed to his
rebellion and that therefore he couldn't
simply take over a town and then move
forward he had to control his rear so
the way he did that was basically turn
his is really pretty bloody troops loose
on every town and there were continuing
large-scale atrocities typically the the
men of military age would be herded into
the local bullring and machine-gunned
there's a description by a journalist
who went to one of these places after
the killing was over and he said I've
never seen four inches of blood covering
the entire surface of a bullring but
there's a lot of blood in 1800 bodies so
that was that aspect of the war and a
terrible aspect indeed the slogan in in
Madrid was they shall not pass later on
it was changed to something more like we
are going to win but but this sign this
sign reflected the kind of desperation
in the early months of the warm Franco
had basically trained hardened forces
and since the leadership of the Spanish
army had defected to Franco side the
army had basically been decapitated and
didn't have any leadership so all the
local labor unions and other
organizations even the anarchists put
together militias fought with whatever
rifles and weapons they could get their
hands on there were times when the only
weapons available were the ones the guys
had in the front
that they were using and the only way
you could get one was to wait til
someone was shot and then run forward
and picked up his weapon to keep using
it it was not at all clear that that
Franco wasn't going to march directly to
Madrid and take over the capital and
basically win the war that way here is
Franco I foot for overweight they called
him Frankie boy in the military school
where he got his training and his
violent socialization but a pretty
remarkable leader when you think about
it if somewhat unimaginative about doing
anything else but fighting a ground war
he was trained that way as a colonial
general in North Africa just about the
time that Madrid was to fall one of the
great phenomena of the war turned up
these were the International Brigade
errs in this case mostly from Europe
anti-nazi forces from Germany and France
and Belgium England a little bit later
about six months later it took a little
longer to get it organized there were
about 6,000 American volunteers 70%
members of the Communist Party as so
many people were doing the Great
Depression
a lot of longshoremen who had just been
kind of radicalized fighting off the
shipowners Union along the in the harbor
in New York City and in San Francisco LA
they'd all converged on New York City
and taken a ship over and volunteered
volunteered their lives to fight for
what might have seemed a very abstract
clause but was not was for many people
in this war I think this is why so many
volunteered they were ultimately about
40,000 volunteers and of those half were
killed during the war
why did they volunteer they really
deeply hoped and believed that if the
war if the fascists could be defeated in
Spain they might prevent another world
scale war and who knows they might have
but unfortunately they lost that's a
general picture of the war and I think
from now on you simply have to think of
the two forces fighting back and forth
and Franco slowly always reinforced by
Germany and Italy whenever he was losing
because once those two countries once
Mussolini and Hitler committed
themselves to winning they really
couldn't afford to lose the war let the
franco lose the war so whenever he was
failing
they simply fed in more more material
more forces in the air and supported him
and italy actually supplied about a
hundred thousand soldiers during the
course of the war one of the reasons
italy didn't quite make it through the
Second World War is that it had expended
so many men and so much money fighting
in Spain just before the Second World
War so let me move now to the more
specific aspects that I looked at one of
the most remarkable things that happened
during the Spanish Civil War was the
development for the first time in War of
Steward blood and Steward blood carried
out to the front lines for frontline
transfusion there were two separate
operations and they weren't even really
aware of each other until about a year
into the war one organized by a
charismatic and communist thoracic
surgeon from Canada who who was sick of
Canada because he tried to install a
National Health Service there and Canada
was then a very conservative country and
didn't
anything to do with it so Norman Beth
Hyun who was a real firebrand thought
well where else can I do some good in
the world and he looked at the war and
said I'm going to Spain once he got to
Spain he didn't want to simply be
another surgeon working on the wounded
on the frontlines he wanted to do
something that would stand out and he
quickly realized that what was as he saw
casualties being carried back from the
front lines all the way back to rear
hospitals before they got much treatment
they were bleeding out
they were arriving at the rearguard
hospitals basically and sanguin aidid
and he realized that the way to do this
wasn't to move the people to the Haute
the hospital but to move at least the
blood to the frontlines so he and his
fellow organizers put together a program
in Madrid where they had a thousand
Madrid women the men were all fighting
thousand Madrid women donate a pint of
blood every month which was then treated
with sodium citrate to prevent clotting
stored in bottles sterile bottles and
refrigerated and he acquired a big fish
delivery truck that had a refrigeration
system in it and he then with his aides
went driving around delivering blood
like he says at one point like a milkman
to the to the frontlines and saved not
only a lot of lives in the Spanish Civil
War but set up a technology that then
had immediate and much wider application
during the Second World War and saved
countless more lives then one of the
pictures that I don't have here and it
wasn't able to get for the book but it
just dazzled me when I saw it was a
photograph of a table full of bottles of
blood that that Bethune's people had
gotten ready to be put in the truck to
take to the front lines
the bottles were wine bottles and milk
bottles
the technology was so new and they had
not yet standardized the containers so
here are all everything looks like good
red wine right so this is one of the
ambulances that Bethune and his crews
used they were present outside of the
town of Malaga when it was destroyed by
Franco's forces with great loss of life
and great suffering and this was an
exodus of thousands of mostly women and
children streaming out of Malaga and the
south southern Mediterranean coast of
Spain trying to get away knowing that
the Moroccan forces were notorious for
for rape for slaughter for killing
people in imaginative ways and stealing
everything they could get their hands on
which obviously Franco and his people
encouraged another figure in the war
that you may well have read his
wonderful book homage to Catalonia this
is George Orwell Orwell turned up one
day in Madrid having just come down from
England and basically said to whomever
he bumped into where can I join now he
he wanted to write about the war and he
didn't really know what the the politics
were except he himself was way to the
left but then so was the rest of the
Republic that he would encounter and he
finally bumped into a woman who was a
member of parliament who was there
representing a political party she
didn't know who he was and she really
didn't trust him
she thought who is this weird-looking
eight feet tall man yeah skinny and
Haggard and and doesn't seem to know why
he's here she thought he might be a spa
she didn't know whether she wanted to
help him or not but then she noticed
that he had a pair of brand-new boots
hanging over his shoulder which he
explained to her he had bought and
brought with him because his feet were
so big he'd heard that there wouldn't be
any boots in size in Spain
and she thought well my god anybody
who's that dedicated to joining the war
this must be George Orwell so she so she
sent him to to one of the organization's
the plume vo um which was a a branch of
communist one of one of the many
different semi communist parties in
Spain's extraordinarily labyrinth in
politics which I don't going to do much
in the war in the book or well fought a
really sat on the frontlines all winter
got got fleas in life's like everyone
else out there writes about it with
great irony and some bitterness finally
came in in Madrid and got a bath after
his six months on the lines and then was
stuck again because Madrid at that point
was having a little internecine
revolution of its own among the various
political groups so he was stuck on a
roof with some of his guys defending a
building for three days with another
party's militia over in the other roof
across the street pointing their guns at
him then he had to go back out and then
ironically or strangely and this is
really one of the details that I found
most fascinating he was as I said quite
tall he made the mistake of popping his
head up above the trenches one day and
there were snipers of course he took a
bullet right through his throat if it
had been half an inch farther in either
direction he would have been killed
which he understood in which he wrote
about as it happened it just traumatized
one of the nerves that control the
speech so he sort of whispered for about
six months but otherwise he was fine you
know to his but he at that point he
really decided it's time to go home
he said I'm just eating food that
somebody else can eat and I think he
probably he had gotten a little bit of
an advance from a publisher to to write
this book and I think he his advance
would probably run out any of you are
writers you know what that means it's
time to go home and write another and of
course we all know this story Ernest
Hemingway and Martha Gellhorn they had
met in Florida when Gellhorn had gone
down there with with her mother to rest
up from her father father's death in the
previous year Hemingway had immediately
started courting her all over the land
and she wanting to report the war went
over to Spain and they quickly met up
there in that hotel Florida which some
of you probably have read about in the
recent nicely done book on the subject I
spend a little time with them because
how could you write about Spain and not
but also because of all the books and I
must say I probably read 200 of all the
books written about the Spanish Civil
War there's really nothing better than
for Whom the Bell Tolls despite the fact
that it's officially a novel I mean
there's so much there that's based on
Hemingway's two periods three months
each of being in Spain and reporting and
in between going back to the United
States and raising enough money to buy
20 especially custom-made ambulances for
Spain where the Ford company would make
the the body and then the whole the
coach work would all be done by hand and
then the thing would be shipped over
Hemingway basically spent every paiement
penny he had had to go get an advance
for another book in order to keep the
ambulances flowing into Spain but he
also did some wonderful reporting while
he was there this distinguished presence
is JBS Haldane one of the great 20th
century biologists he was asked to come
to Spain by the Republic when they
thought early in the war that Franco
might be using poison gas artillery
shells they've had a few people come
down with what looked like symptoms of
gas poisoning
they were shells that were painted green
which was a particular type of shell
from the first world war Holliday n--'s
father who was a distinguished biologist
as well had done a lot of work on poison
gases in the first world war and Haldane
as a young Oxford student had helped him
so all day and volunteered to come down
between terms of the University of
London where he taught and here he is
with one of his people testing out a gas
mask
he wrote brilliantly about the effects
of bombing and whether gas was even a
useful wartime method of fighting in
these bombings of cities that were going
on he didn't think it was particularly
effective that high explosives really
were much better he wanted to tear down
buildings and kill a lot of people and
of course by then Hitler had loaned
Franco what was called the Condor Legion
which was a 5,000 man force of bombers
and fighters the latest planes that
Germany had sometimes actually pulled
out of the developing air force that
Hitler was putting together with that
magneri and bravado the Condor Legion
they came over to serve as Franco's Air
Force and in particular to work on the
problem of how you can burn down a city
with with purely with bombing the leader
of the Condor Legion the German general
of the Luftwaffe who led that force had
actually been studying in Italy the
writings of do a the man who invented
the whole idea of strategic and carpet
bombing
he was ready to try out these ideas in
Spain and they did indeed do just that
the most famous of all of course being
the bombing of the 6000 population
Basque town of Guernica in the north of
Spain on a bright clear sunny afternoon
in April of 1937 planes coming over with
high explosives to knock down the
buildings followed by planes carrying
two-pound magnesium incendiary bombs to
start fires followed by planes carrying
20-pound fragmentation bombs to kill the
firemen so that they couldn't put the
fires out of the six thousand are
perhaps as many as 10,000 the town had a
lot of refugees in it at that time of
the several thousands of people at least
500 and perhaps a thousand were killed
in one afternoon with fire bombing in
the whole town was burned down this was
the first deliberate destruction of a
city by aerial bombardment in the
history of war and in my mind there's a
direct line between Garnica and Aurora
and Nagasaki a line of development of
the concept of using destruction from
the air and of course the great irony is
that the method of using fire bombing to
burn down cities came back to haunt
Germany during the Second World War when
the United States and England developed
a bombing campaign in support of Stalin
and Russian forces who were really the
only Allied forces on the ground in
Europe until 1944 and Stalin was
constantly threatening to sign a
separate peace with Germany and the only
thing we could think to do too
convincing
we were not deliberately trying to let
him fight the war alone was to use
aerial bombardment that was one of the
reasons there were technical reasons as
well we our bomb site didn't work very
well
the famous Norden bombsight had to be
plain had to be held steady for three
minutes in a line in order to get the
bomb site set up and then you could drop
the bombs and get the hell out but
obviously when there's anti-aircraft
fire all around you you don't like to
hold your plane in a straight line for
three minutes over a target we were
dropping bombs as far away as five miles
from the target so the Norden bombsight
was useless and one solution was simply
to extend the bombing from so-called
pinpoint bombing to bombing industrial
plants and if industrial plants then why
not the homes and apartment houses where
the workers lived and with that
rationale pretty soon you've got a big
enough target that you can hit it and of
course grenita solved Picasso's problem
that year which was he committed to
painting a mural for the Spanish
Pavilion at the Paris Exposition of 1937
and he could not think of anything to
paint he had gone through a year when he
hadn't painted at all believe it or not
this man who could paint a masterpiece
ended day or two the reason seems to
have been not very high blown he was
going through a divorce and under French
law there was like California mutual
property law and he wasn't going to
paint any more paintings that his wife
would get would get so so for a year
Picasso didn't paint then and then when
he made a commitment to to doing the
mural for the Spanish pavilion for three
months that was January 37 for three
months he really could not think of
anything to paint and then he read in
the
Paris newspapers about the bombing of
Guernica and it really infuriated him
and he saw his subject and he went about
the business of painting what I think is
certainly his best-known painting but I
think is also one of his greatest
paintings I won't even try to go into
any exposition of the painting I'm sure
you've all looked at it and thought
about it before when I was an
undergraduate back in the 1950s I used
to take the train down from New Haven to
New York this painting was had then at
the Museum of Modern Art and I would
just sit there for an hour and just look
at it I had come from a farm in the
Midwest and this was my introduction to
modern art and it just dazzled me then
and it dazzles me now less well-known
for a sad reason is that Murrow also
painted a painting for that exhibition
on comparable scale you can see him here
on his ladder painting this
extraordinary angry peasant and I put
the stamp he did for the same exhibition
next year it's here you can get a sense
of the color but notice the difference
between the two peasants the one for the
stamp is kind of a cheery guy with a big
arm saying no pasaran basically whereas
the other one with this spindly neck is
is furious and prepared with the sickle
in his hand to kill so Murrow put his
feelings into that painting certainly
sadly after the exhibition closed the
painting was which was made of six
panels of a kind of something called
Celotex which was a made out of sugar
cane it's kind of a fiber board material
the panels were loaded on a truck and
disappeared painting has never been
found
whether it was hit by bombing or someone
stole it I don't know but it's
disappeared forever from history and the
only thing left are these simple black
photographs of it I focused with all the
famous people around the war I came
finally to focus on some individuals not
so well-known that maybe not known at
all
this is dr. Edward Barsky who was a
surgeon in New York of a distinguished
family of surgeons but himself of
Communists believe it or not Barsky and
also ill with colitis Barsky volunteered
for the war after raising a great deal
of money for ambulances and and then
thinking who's going to go over there
put him together there supplies for a
complete mobile hospital unit and then
it became obvious that he was the winner
needed to lead this operation so he went
over he participated in every way in the
war he did a the kind of heroic surgery
that people do in wartime where the
surgeon operates for 30 hours non-stop
and then collapses for a few hours and
then goes back to work he also came back
to the United States from time to time
to raise more money what was amazing to
me is I found a cache of documents that
had never seen the light of day really
New York University's Tama man library
which has a large labor-related
collection including a complete book
manuscript of barsky's a memoir 400
pages long that he wrote with the help
of a woman journalist that was so Brown
with age that we couldn't even scan it
the type typewriter type was was barely
darker than than the paper by then this
should have been published years ago but
one of the tragedies of the war is that
people came back from the war with
whatever stories they had to tell and
within four months the Second World War
began in Europe and it simply swamped
out everything and after the war with
the rise of McCarthy
anti-communism in the united states
Barsky was harassed by the house on
American Activities Committee found in
contempt of Congress because he wouldn't
give up the names of his comrades thrown
in federal prison for six months and had
his license lifted medical license for
six months and then got out and went
right back to doing what he did so well
he participated in the civil rights
movement in the South he participated in
the in the protests against the war in
Vietnam he continued throughout his life
to be the idealistic and dedicated man
he was but that is a book that really
still needs to be published and it was
full of wonderful stories including the
phrase that makes the title of the book
Barsky at one point in this memoir says
war is hell with all of the metaphysical
complexities of that word but it's all
so damn good company so hell and good
company and then I just I fell in love
with patience darted beautiful English
nurse big blue eyes patients came to
Spain and turned out not to be very
patient
the Spanish were then as I guess they
are now a very patriarchal culture and
they didn't think these nurses should be
exposed to the front lines so they put
them in the back taking care of people
who had TB or whatever and Darton just
tore the place up until they finally let
her go into as it were into battle she
would go into Spanish hospitals which
were decrepit places Spain was really
behind the times and its medical
services typically the the nurses were
nuns and when men came in who were
wounded they felt too modest to undress
them or clean them or bathe them or care
for them they would basically put them
on a on a lice ridden bed
and just leave them there and you know
they'd feed them but they wouldn't take
care of their bodies so Darton would
arrive with a few other English nurses
and and a bunch of Spanish chicas who
wanted to learn how to be nurses which
had not been allowed before and cleaned
the place up and put everybody out of
the way she describes one hospital where
they had been throwing all the hospital
waste and I mean every kind of waste
from severed limbs to to bowel movements
out the back windows
she said all you had to do was just flip
the window open and the huge cloud of
flies would emerge all over so she got
the young medical students and the
chicas and the nurses and they cleaned
the place up and that's the way she
worked until she met one of the members
of the International Brigade in the
course of he was ill with typhoid one of
the problems the Spanish evidently were
immune to typhoid because they've been
exposed to it in the course of their
growing up but the people coming from
outside were not so this man up here his
name is Robert a Quist who was a
anti-nazi German Jew from Palestine his
family his family was one of the
original settlers in Palestine in the
early 1930s and he had come to volunteer
for the war she met Robert and nursed
him back to health they fell in love and
they began catching a little bit of time
together in the course of the war
whenever they could he had to go back to
fight but they kept bumping into each
other in various places and having a
little bit of time to be in love it was
they were not the only couple by any
means that found each other in the
course of this this curious literary
human war one of the most important
battles of the war if one of the saddest
was an attempt toward the end you
remember how divided the country was
with Catalonia over here as kind of the
last piece that Franco its forces hadn't
reconquered there was a river there the
Elbe no not elbow what is it every River
yes and they planned a surprise attack
across the river to see if they could
move Franco's forces back from being
from basically cutting Spain in half so
this plank bridge was built and boats
were built in some of the abandoned
churches in the course of the spring of
1938 and then in early July the first
forces crossed the river on this little
pontoon bridge and then a larger bridge
was built boats went across it was
ultimately a forlorn hope the Franco's
forces by then had so much more Tillery
so many planes and bombs that as one of
the fighters said later we were finally
fighting off the planes in the artillery
with just our fists so there were lots
of people gravely wounded and patients
and her nursing crew and the doctors
with them had to find a place close to
the river close to the front lines where
they could treat the most severely
wounded quickly before they expired they
found this cave it's called santa lucia
cave been continuously occupied all the
way back into the Pleistocene by humans
it's about a hundred and fifty feet wide
we visited it when we were in Spain it's
a memorial now the ceiling is about
twenty or thirty feet above the floor
and it reaches back into the mountain
perhaps 30 or 40 feet and at the back
there was a spring of fresh water
fact the water was said to cure
illnesses of the eye and people made
pilgrimages to Santa Lucia for to put
water on their eyes here this group of
medics built a 120 bed hospital setting
up beds on the rocky floor of the cave
to receive the wounded as they were
brought up from the a burrow back across
the river and here for treatment it was
all but hopeless this is patients
sitting down in the valley
the nice thing about the cave was it was
facing a narrow valley too narrow for
the Condor Legion fighters to be able to
dive in and strafe into the cave and of
course that huge done lintel above the
cave protected it from bombing overhead
but let me just read to you what
patience has to say as a kind of final
coda of the story this is my voice
starting the road that passed above the
cave hospital led to the battle front
from the cave vestibule day and night
darkened patients Darton watched
truckloads of the last Republican draft
childrens she remembers 15 and 16 year
olds in the last column going up to the
front it was more than she could bear
she thought although there was always
more to bear in war particularly when
your side is losing quote and we saw
what happened when they got to the front
these terrible smashed up people
streaming in and to hear those kids
singing as they went up it was terrible
when I thought what was going to happen
to them and it got me down frightfully
we were working terribly hard it was
very uncomfortable very dark in that
cave and almost everyone who came in was
pulseless and seriously ill I was on
nights and this darkness and the
discomfort and the seriousness of it
I thought it wasn't worth it I thought
no war is worth all this this misery and
this horror unquote perhaps no war is
not even that first desperate war
against fascism to which the Spanish
people were abandoned by the democracies
and by the Soviet Union as well
so that of Spain's 24 million souls
fully half a million died directly or
from hunger and disease or immediately
afterward in Franco's hundred-thousand
vindictive executions the more that
patience darkened could bear at least
came on quickly at the end of the first
week of the Battle of the Ebro the tall
young British nurse Robert asked West's
cherished pancake he called her pancake
because she lost so much weight
received a letter dated 31 July 1938
from Sargent Bert Robin forty first
Battalion machine gun company addressed
esteemed comrade quote I ask you above
all to accept these lines calmly the
letter began and continued on 27 July
1938 Robert was killed struck a mine and
died immediately
a few days before he charged me with
notifying you in the event of his death
at the same time I am sending all his
letters to you yours to him as well as
his parents and asked you to notify them
of his death
sergeant Raman went on to praise his
comrade we know what we have lost in him
in the next day's Fritz Jensen the
Viennese physician hearing of patients
is grief and exercising Wars curious
compassion arranged her transfer to the
Battlefront she would say appreciatively
the move to the front was like a sort of
therapy before she left the cave
Hospital however santa lucia the waters
of which are said to heal afflictions of
the eyes Darton wrote robert equus
parents in palestine with news of his
death she wrote of her love for him and
of his for her she told them he had
loved them and had cherished the
photographs they had sent she assured
them these last eight months were full
of joy for him patience Darton one among
40,000 international volunteers changed
her mind then about the worth of war of
that war at least war as one man she
knew had fought it as she was fighting
it for me and for many she wrote of her
husband interred now in a common grave
among his comrades he was a revelation
of how to live and fight against the
thing that is trying to ruin the world
patience lived on through a long
productive life this is the Condor
Legion victory parade their spelling out
Franco's name this is patience late in
life in the last month of her life she
went for the first time back to Spain
the late-1990s where they were having a
reunion of the men and women who were
left from the International Brigades and
sat on the stage with the others who had
been in Spain with her received the
honorary citizenship in Spain that the
new government now that Franco was gone
had was conferring on these people who
had come to fight simply from their
hopes in the goodness of their hearts
and patience that night she had lupus by
then it was ill she went into the
hospital in Madrid that night and died
the next morning
now just to bring this forward I give
you this graph this is a graph of deaths
man-made deaths for more starting at
beginning of the 20th century and you
noticed first world war takes us up to
about 6 million deaths
in one year 1918 I suppose the second
world there there's the Spanish Civil
War that beep in the middle actually the
smaller one the smaller one right there
and then the Second World War the most
destructive war in human history
15 million deaths in 1943 partly from
the Holocaust partly from the the actual
battles but then something very curious
happens in 1945 yes man-made deaths from
war drop to a low of around 2 million
and pretty much stayed there for the
rest of the 20th century and up to today
now there are various speculations about
why major war seems to have been
abandoned at least I think the only one
that's really credible is the nuclear
weapons made the kinds of wars that that
that blighted the 20th century no longer
possible to fight the dream of the 30s
was that aerial bombardment would be a
sufficient deterrent to stop the war but
it wasn't destructive enough the bombs
that were dropped on Hiroshima and
Nagasaki implied a level of destruction
that seems to have convinced even as
belligerent a state as the United States
or the Soviet Union or any of the other
religions of the 20th century that they
would their own nation would be
destroyed if we or someone else tried to
destroy an enemy there are arguments on
both sides and I there's no way to prove
it one way or the other
but as history as time continues if
world scale war truly has been ended I
think it will be because we finally
discovered an explosive that basically
is infinite in potential scale we're
left then today all these years after
this little
or that was so hopeful and so sadly
scotch those hopes we're left in with
the world where on the one hand we're
living a much more peaceful world a
couple million deaths a year is nothing
to be proud of to be sure but it's four
million fewer than died from smoking
so we found a we found an inoculation if
you will but the other side of that of
course is that if the bombs go off then
we will have destruction on a scale far
beyond anything that this graph depicts
even it turns out a small regional
nuclear war say between India and
Pakistan would produce sufficient smoke
and soot from burning cities to cause a
drop in average annual temperatures
worldwide of about two to three degrees
which is enough to reproduce the summer
without a year without a summer of 1816
when the volcano Tambora caused the Sun
to be darkened enough to cause hard
freezes in New England in July so we
live in a very different and ironically
more peaceful but more precarious age
than these people did and I think
perhaps the last thing I would say is
it's probably a lot harder to be heroic
thank
thank you Richard thank you
[Music]